if you're out there we need your help
the storm came
the monsters followed they took
everything about towns of families the
few of us left are in serious danger now
it's time to fight back
all we need is a leader and that's you
a lot of monsters
got massive pork
killer chat
we stick together they don't stand a
chance
[Music]
the world of Fortnight is filled with
places to explore and link to scavenge
collect building and crafting materials
while traveling across landscapes where
no two are ever the same you never know
what you'll find
or where you'll find it
make sure to go inside buildings
searching can pay off everything you
collect can be used to protect yourself
or help the survivors out there who need
you for protection from the storm you
and your friends will need to build
forts use a variety of building pieces
to keep enemies at bay and make a strong
defense edit mode lets you customize
pieces to fit your needs
make doors or windows or get more
creative stronger materials like stone
or metal will give your fort more
staying power being able to build on the
fly lets you respond to threats quickly
and adapt when you need to
you didn't make all this just to watch
again knock down defend your fort the
way you want build sniper towers if
that's your style
or use all of the powerful traps you've
crafted to make a maze of deaths that'll
do the dirty work for you when monsters
do take a bite out of your defenses you
can repair and reinforce them during the
heat of battle keep an eye out for weak
spots because the enemy sees them too
use your imagination build the ultimate
fort and use it to withstand all the bad
things the storm will throw at you
[Music]
with what you've harvested you can craft
hundreds of weapons for melee to heavy
arms
[Music]
make traps to set up the perfect
surprise attack or use gadgets that will
help you and your team
manage your resource as well and you can
be fully prepared for whatever is headed
your way your friends will help you
succeed each hero is a specialized
version of one of the basic types
constructors soldiers Outlanders and
ninjas each hero you collect comes with
individual advantages that fulfill
different roles on your team
of course constructors are skilled at
building forts but they also provide
valuable crowd control primed for combat
soldiers bring Crenn aides as well as
the big guns and
the biggest gun
Outlanders are the best at harvesting
and have some unique tools at their
disposal
all that and a mean right hook finally
there are ninjas great for melee and
really into throwing stars they're good
for getting into and out of trouble
quickly collect cards to get heroes with
different skills more heroes equals more
abilities that your disposal get your
friends together for a well-rounded team
cooperation can make all the difference
the people need you rescue survivors and
give them a home defend them with
everything you've got
don't seek shelter make it
[Music]